desde luego y continuando con la visión
del compañero Godoy Pues esa búsqueda de
soy el nuevo Qué malata turk estamos
cumpliendo los 100 años de la República
turca somos más fuertes que nunca somos
una nación claro refiriéndose al tema
sobre todo kurdo que es lo que más
afecta ya que bueno son La minoría más
grande de Turquía de hecho con una
relevancia política fundamental teniendo
en torno al 15% tanto en población como
en cargos electos En definitiva en la
zona más precisamente otra vez la
fronteriza con Siria con Irak y con Irán
pues son mayoría en muchos lugares y En
definitiva bueno Mostrar que a pesar de
todo lo que pueda haber por otras partes
que la unidad de Turquía es irrefutable
y también bueno seguir esa búsqueda de
soy el que malata del siglo XXI seguidme
que qué mal quito las cosas malas del
pasado quitó la debilidad del imperio
hizo una República moderna fuerte Pues
también Bueno hay un detalle también muy
interesante en todo esto que es un
detalle más de semiótica y de historia
en la plaza taxim en Estambul en el
Monumento a la república que preside por
la parte central el mismo quema lata
tiene a su izquierda al a la embajador
aralo de la unión soviética por él apoyo
que la unión soviética también le dio a
la República turca en sus primeros
momentos y de hecho ese eje de apoyo
Rusia Turquía es algo que también desde
Turquía han buscado para resolver
conflictos como el de Siria para otros
conflictos en el mar Negro tensiones y
en el cáucaso es decir que también no
deja de estar presente en el fondo a
través de atatürk esas relaciones hacia
el este y por cierto también un detalle
de última hora el mismo presidente de
Hungría Víctor Urban también ha
felicitado a erdogan por su Victoria
también con una parte del tuit en Turco
y no deja de ser interesante por
precisamente que Hungría
digamos esa Europa lo que Turquía es
Oriente medio es decir en Hungría es
verdad son cristianos católicos pero son
húngaros y digamos que no hay húngaros
alrededor tienen a latinos de Rumanía a
eslavos de serbio de Croacia o a
germanos como los austriacos pero
húngaros no hay más que eso sí digamos
que tienen esa búsqueda también de un
eje geopolítico global de ahí las
reuniones tan intensas entre Hungría
Turquía y otros países de ese mundo
Turco entonces bueno no dejamos de ver
ahora esos primeros movimientos también
en Europa que son muy importantes para
para ver cómo es el posicionamiento de
cada uno también y mismo lugar teniendo
en cuenta la posición que representa
Hungría dentro de la Unión Europea
especialmente y Turquía dentro de la
otan es decir una posición sui generis
de todos los demás miembros siguen lo
que diga Estados Unidos
pues salvo alguna reticencias de Francia
pero sobre todo las posiciones de
Hungría de Turquía son las más
destacables por No dejarse llevar por la
corriente general y bueno vemos como
precisamente esas amistades de erdogan
hacia Turquía se van notando en la
actualidad